look into the camera blink once if you
die blink twice if you live just stare
straight ahead if nothing I think like
23 times I don't even know I didn't see
the movie
I read my pages and but then there's
seen all sorts of things that happen
post me being there you become ticket
you counties find out you really want me
to tell you why just tell me tell
everybody that's what happens if I speak
grown ass some someone are kind of
intercepted something those guys come
down and they try to strangle you you
become quite the artist on the tour you
you've drawn a few what you've drawn a
few posters haven't you yeah it's that
all about and what do your co-stars
think about that rain it was like what's
up with you throwing on my face and I
was like there's my post drive there
have a go if you want I'm just an
artistic flair that you know I mean I
walk past those posters for a few days
during that there the press conference
and got real sick of them so by the way
you finally get to see this movie you've
waited so long expectations right now
I mean I've heard nothing but incredible
things and and and a different buzz
about this than I have in previous films
like I'm nervous because you just are
you yeah of course you always are you
know it's always a nerve-wracking
experience but I don't know this was we
literally left it all on the field on
this one and it was a combination about
22 films 10 years of work and so I think
we all have a sense of pride there's a
bit of sweet quality to it because it's
the last time this gathering or this
group that people is gonna be here
together and are you your kids favorite
Avenger I don't think so now I try and
convince him you know to sort of give
them special treats but now they're not
into it I think they like Captain
America they like Wonder Woman
yeah the Hulk but then they met Mark
Ruffalo and they're like where's the
Hulk and I was like well uh kids you
know what do you do
[Music]